depuis un an faire l'épicerie est devenu
un véritable casse-tête pour la
madelinienne Annie Landry elle analyse
longuement le coût de chaque aliment
cette 99 il se résigne parfois à laisser
l'article sur la tablette le fromage
s'épouvantable une brique à 8 et 22
ou à 10 c'est 33 on n'aura pas de
fromage cette semaine
j'ai fait des épiceries de 500 dollars
par semaine c'était pas pour le mois
c'était juste pour la semaine donc j'ai
j'ai commencé à angoisser parce que j'ai
des bouches à nourrir la mère qui élève
seule deux adolescents a dû faire des
choix difficiles alors même jusqu'à
vider les tirelires de ces garçons pour
tenter de payer les factures et quand il
y a plus rien dans les banques
le j'ai commencé à paniquer parce que
c'était soit payé le logement payer
l'électricité le chauffage évidemment je
faisais de l'insomnie j'avais j'avais
honte aussi parce que j'étais plus
capable de payer les cartes de dîner
pour l'école et le les comptes
commencent à être en retard mais
vraiment le sentiment de pas être
capable d'acheter du pain puis du lait
une étude réalisée en 2016 révélait que
le prix du panier d'épicerie aux Îles de
la Madeleine étaient 16% plus élevé qu'à
Montréal une mise à jour de cette étude
est en cours les résultats attendu cet
été c'est sûr que tout le monde trouve
ça coûte cher ça coûte cher cet agent de
développement social rappelle que
l'éloignement a un prix notamment à
l'épicerie le couvercle qu'on est dans
une région éloignée qu'on est dans une
région rurale Savary avec la surface
d'épicerie évidemment plus on est dans
un milieu
urbain plus les surfaces sont grandes
dès qu'on s'éloigne ça coûte plus cher
dès qu'on est des petits milieux ça
coûte plus cher aussi
le facteur insulaire
il y a quatre supermarchés aux Îles de
la Madeleine un boni choix et trois
coopératives IgA tous propriétés de
Sobeys mais les prix et les spéciaux ne
sont pas toujours les mêmes qu'ailleurs
au Québec la preuve hygea distribue une
circulaire différente aux Îles de la
Madeleine les rabais offerts sont
identiques à ceux de la bannière des
marchés traditions où les prix sont
généralement plus élevés que IgA en
raison des petits volumes de vente
difficile donc pour les madelinos
d'avoir accès à des promotions
intéressantes d'autant plus que les
produits en rabais ne sont pas toujours
disponibles sur les tablettes des
épiceries de l'archipel je me suis
vraiment senti mal pendant des semaines
très mal
à me demander si j'étais pas mieux de
déménager dans des endroits où il y
avait encore
des Costco métro d'autres parce que
c'est comme si on n'avait pas le choix
il y a définitivement un monopole de la
part de sobies sur l'ensemble des
épiceries aux yeux de la Madeleine le
député des Îles de la Madeleine croient
que cette main mise de saubaise piège
les insulaires et contribue à tirer les
prix vers le haut et la compétition
qu'on voit à travers le Québec ou
ailleurs entre des grandes chaînes par
exemple métro ou encore
sauvés ou encore les maxis de ce monde
mais ici cette concurrence là elle est
nulle Radio-Canada comparé le prix d'un
panier d'épicerie composé des les mêmes
aliments dans différentes bannières dans
le plus grand IgA des Îles de la
Madeleine la facture s'élève à 55
dollars tandis que les de 49$ dans une
succursale de Montréal au maxi c'est
même produit côte à peine 38$ c'est 30%
de moins que le prix payé dans
l'archipel les épiciers madelinaux ont
tous décliné nous demandent d'entrevue
en nous expliquant que ces obèses qui
fixent les prix malgré plusieurs
tentatives sur base n'a jamais donné
suite à nos demandes ici on a une
requête
une lecture romaine qu'à cela tienne
Annie Landry a décidé de trouver
elle-même des solutions pour réduire sa
facture d'épicerie elle a fait l'achat
d'une tour de culture aéroponique qui
lui permet de faire pousser des fruits
et légumes durant toute l'année c'est
beaucoup moins stressant pour moi même
si on sait pas où est-ce qu'on s'en va
avec avec l'inflation et et récession
mais au moins on va manger à notre faim
et je vais semer et planter et cueillir
tant que je veux elle a également
commencé à faire des réserves de macro
péchés OK et de petits fruits sauvages
des canberge
il est bleuet c'est tout des fruits des
îles évidemment des aliments gratuits
qui lui permettent une certaine
autosuffisance comme le faisait ses
ancêtres on avait traditionnellement ce
savoir là comme insulaire de faire nos
légumes faire pousser nos légumes faire
nos réserves de légumes il faut qu'on
réapprenne à produire une part de
nourriture si on a même pu accès à ce
qui est pêché chez nous etc est-ce qu'on
importe hors de prix je pense qu'il faut
se résigner c'est comme encore la
résilience
elle a vraiment monté de plusieurs
marches la résilience avec l'inflation
de la résilience il en faudra beaucoup
car le prix des aliments pourrait encore
augmenter de à 7% cette année selon
certains experts ici Isabelle Larose
Radio-Canada aux Îles de la Madeleine